it's deeply anti-intellectual and it's
it's frankly racist i think we should
call it out for what it is
if you look at the kind of white
supremacist ideology of the 1950s which
we all denounce
uh it has the same categorization as the
critical race theory ideology of today
you reduce people to a racial essence
back then and today it's whiteness and
blackness
you create a group identity-based
hierarchy again it's different but it's
the same concept
and then these critical race theory
trainings are essentially denouncing
people not on their individual
characteristics
but on their inborn identity this is
something that was wrong in 1950
it's wrong today and we should be very
on high alert
and we should all be working together to
jettison this ideology
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report as always guys make sure you're
subscribed on our youtube channel and
have that notification bell clicked on
and joining me today is a research
fellow at the discovery
institute center on wealth poverty and
morality
and contributing editor at the city
journal and perhaps more importantly
mr critical race theory himself
christopher ruffo welcome to the reuben
report
it's great to be with you what do you
think about that title
mr critical race theory
i think it's a little bit misleading
because i think a lot of the
proponents of critical race theory uh
would disagree with that uh they would
say i'm kind of mr
anti-crt more than anything
all right well we're gonna discuss that
for the next half hour
and then we'll let the people decide uh
so
really why i wanted to have you on is
you're you're one of the people
at least in the twitter world although
now you've you've made it to tucker so
that's a
that's a nice bump that has been
explaining critical race theory
clearly and and honestly and openly
and it is a set of ideas that basically
has infiltrated almost
every part of society and has so much to
do with
why we're seeing such chaos at the
moment and why everybody
is sort of picking their set of facts or
their world view
and we can't come together on anything
so i really want to just unpack
all of that with you so that my audience
can understand it a little bit more
because i think when you say
critical race theory people don't know
exactly what it means there's a lot of
different definitions all that so just
one thing quickly before we do that
which is
how did you get involved in all of this
in the first place
and then we'll take it from there yeah
you know i've been reporting the last
two years on homelessness
addiction mental illness and kind of
west coast street disorder so
this has been a bit of a departure but
it all started when i got a
whistleblower email
that said hey the city of seattle is now
holding racially segregated diversity
trainings
uh and assist the segregated system for
white employees is called
interrupting whiteness and internalized
white superiority
and this just immediately peaked my
interest i filed a records request
i forgot about it for a couple months
and then got this trove of documents in
that was just
astonishing and you know i've been
following the kind of
conceptual ideas of critical race theory
for the last few years
uh but this was the first time i'd see
it really implemented in a way that was
crystal clear
that was extremely divisive and then
once i released them publicly it kind of
took on a life of its own and i became
really the kind of key source for
whistleblowers in every institution in
the united states and since then i've
had
more than a thousand whistleblowers
contact me everything from the smallest
school districts and middle america
to the highest levels of the federal
agencies
and they're all saying that critical
race theory has become the dominant
ideology in these institutions
it's ripping us apart but we're scared
to speak out
and that's why we're contacting you yeah
and that's why i thought this was
such an interesting topic because you
know
for the the years that i've been doing
my show
i've had on an awful lot of people who
have been fighting these ideas but there
wasn't sort of a name around it there
wasn't like a way to look at it through
at an institutional
level so when you're getting all of
these emails from from little
institutions up to the
big federal stuff it's like i've i've
been seeing these emails for the last
five years and we've been seeing you
know brett weinstein at evergreen state
what happened
and lindsay shepard and just the litany
of
examples of people fighting this thing
okay so let's just do 101 here
what is critical race theory
so that's a question with a thousand
answers but the best that i can describe
it it's basically
you take the marxian dichotomy of
oppressor and oppressed
so you have one group in society that is
the oppressor one group that is
that is the oppressed traditionally
that's been the kind of bourgeoisie and
the proletariat so it's an economic
stratification
critical race theory basically contends
that we're going to do away with the
economic categorization for now
and we're going to essentially graft
identity politics
onto this marxian dichotomy so that it's
no longer
the bourgeoisie and the proletariat it's
whiteness and blackness
it's kind of white americans versus
people of color
so that's really what it is it's an old
marxist idea
that's been repackaged with the racial
politics of our time
so do you see a moment where it went
from an economic theory to a racial
theory was there just like
like a moment that that happened or did
it just slowly infect the whole thing
yeah i think you know there's a many
moments it's a lineage that is a pretty
long lineage but if you can trace it
back to the frankfurt school
and the frankfurt school theorists i
guess now 50 years ago or more
really realized that economic marxism
had its limits
they realized that it couldn't make
inroads in europe and the united states
because we had too big of a middle class
in the united states you have a suburban
house you have an automobile
a washing machine and people didn't
really feel
that that the oppressor oppressed
dynamic of social class was really
speaking to them and so the kind of
marxist theoretician said
we're not going to make success that way
let's figure out how we can set up a new
dynamic that could be more salient
and unfortunately this works it is a it
is something that i don't think has much
basis in reality or in fact
but is tremendously powerful
psychologically and you have an
our elite class has really adopted this
rhetoric
that i think has no basis in their daily
life
but it's become a very potent weapon a
very powerful weapon
that's found resonance because it
combines this kind of innate american
discomfort about race
and then weaponizes it into a political
tool
does it strike you as as sort of deeply
anti-intellectual also i mean that's the
part that is sort of amazing to me when
you see it
seep into the the places of higher
education that are supposed to be about
intellectualism and yet they're taking a
set of ideas
that whittles us all down to our skin
color as if that's the most important
thing
it seems like it's deeply
anti-intellectual not
actually intellectual yeah it's it's
deeply anti-intellectual and it's it's
frankly racist i think we should call it
out for what it is
if you look at the kind of white
supremacist ideology of the 1950s which
we all denounce
uh it has the same categorization as the
critical race theory ideology of today
you reduce people to a racial essence
back then
and today it's whiteness and blackness
you create a group
identity based hierarchy again it's
different but it's the same concept
and then these critical race theory
trainings are essentially denouncing
people not on their individual
characteristics
but on their inborn identity this is
something that was wrong in 1950
it's wrong today and we should be very
on high alert
and we should all be working together to
jettison this ideology
and i think something that's really
important is that if you look at martin
luther king the kind of
uh the kind of gold standard of of how
we should think about the country how we
should think about
a race his philosophy was deeply rooted
in christianity he was obviously a
preacher
but it was also deeply rooted in the
declaration and the constitution and the
work of abraham lincoln
he was a student you can read this in
his essays he was a student of american
history
and realized that we had to kind of
bring forward the highest ideals of the
country
the black lives matter movement the
critical race theory movement
they self-consciously reject the
ideology of martin luther king they
reject the ideology of the declaration
of independence
and they reject the ideology of
christianity wholesale
it's a different lineage it comes from
the kind of marxist theoreticians of the
1960s
and has no kind of resonance in our in
our kind of
organic homegrown cultural tradition
do you see what they want to build on
the other side of this that
that's the part that is unclear to me
like i i get
all of the bad ideas here i think a lot
of my audience because we've been
talking about this stuff forever gets a
lot of bad ideas
but it seems to me that i can't really
see what they want to build i can see
what they want to destroy which is
pretty much everything which is what we
see happening right now hollywood's
crumbling
our cultural institutions are crumbling
our academic institutions are crumbling
our political institutions are crumbling
they've infected everything so i get
the destruction phase but do they even
really talk about
the people that buy into this do they
ever really talk about what they will
build
after this i mean is it really going to
be a world where are we going to have
anti-white laws like is that really
where we're headed with this whole thing
yeah i mean there's there's two ways to
look at that question one is you're
absolutely right um
critical race theory and critical theory
in general is not a philosophy of a
substantive positive
it's a philosophy of pure negation uh
they're arguing that they should
deconstruct existing social institutions
uh point out how they're kind of coded
uh for racial dominance and oppression
and then obliterate them
they're not clear and this goes back all
the way to marx in the 1840s
marx posited that we have to have the
revolution uh we have to destroy the
social order we have to destroy
all of the kind of underpinnings of our
society but
even marx gave no clarity on what the
world looks like after that
it was pure utopianism there was no
concrete
plan or development or even a vision of
what would happen
it's really this blind faith that if you
destroy what's bad
something beautiful and good and eternal
will emerge
but our history in the last 450 years
globally
has shown that that's absolutely wrong
when you demolish a social order when
you empower
ideologues uh that that divide people on
the basis of group identity
it leads to famine it leads to war it
leads to genocide
it leads to everything that is bad in
the world and i don't see
the critical race theorists positing
something a substantive in their in
its place and i think what you can also
see the second way of looking at this
is that if you look at the kind of uh
in practice what emerges look at the
chass you remember the capitol hill
autonomous zone in seattle
black lives matter and anarchists took
it over they said once we get rid of the
police once we get rid of the seattle
government once we have our own kind of
utopia
we are going to set up a government
based on social justice principles
and what happened they set up racially
segregated facilities
there were meetings and gardens and
elsewhere that were explicitly endorsing
racial segregation
and it devolved into a violent nightmare
it had a homicide rate that was 50 times
greater than the city of chicago
it led to the senseless death of
african-american men
and it didn't work and although that's
obviously a very small example
i i think it's a it's an important one
because it gives a kind of glimpse into
what happens
uh when you demolish uh law and order
when you demolish the existing social
order
and you try to replace it with a utopian
vision
so one of the questions i get all the
time from people is
they'll say dave why is it spreading so
quickly
like it's almost as if if you weren't
paying attention to this like if you
weren't watching the
the few youtube channels about it or the
podcast or whatever
you suddenly it was as if it never
existed and then one day it burst forth
and now it's
it's everywhere have you thought about
that just sort of
how it has been able to spread its
tentacles
so seemingly quickly even even for the
people that saw it coming for a while it
does seem like there was suddenly like
a catalyst that that really exploded in
the last six months
yeah i think you're right and i i
thought a lot about that and and i'm
basing it really empirically on
talking to folks in these agencies in
these institutions
um who have been unable to resist it and
i think the explanation is really this
uh critical race theory the intellectual
argument of it
is constructed almost like a mouse trap
it's quite ingenious
and embedded in the premise is that if
you oppose critical race theory yeah
that's merely an expression of your
white privilege of your white
white fragility of your internalized
white superiority and
they make any resistance any
disagreement
uh they just rationalize that as a proof
that you are the thing that they're
fighting against
so it's constructed in a circular way
where you can't truly fight back against
it
and they're using a a very kind of
bare-knuckled
social shaming and social kind of
castigation process where
if you even raise your hand in one of
these trainings and say well you know
this is a little bit simplistic i see it
in a more nuanced way i see it in a more
complex way you're going to be berated
by at least one person in the room who
says you're a racist or a white
supremacist or a fascist or what have
you
and frankly most people who are you know
working a regular job they're raising
families
they don't want to take the risk the
social pressure is so
extraordinary that they essentially just
sit and take it
but i think what we're finding out in
the last few months especially is that
a people have had enough of it it goes
against their experience it's tearing
apart workplaces
and people are starting to finally speak
out i think you know your show
certainly weinstein and james lindsey
and peter bogossian and helen pluck
groves
they laid a theoretical foundation
against critical race theory
but what i'm trying to do and what
others are trying to do is trying to put
that into action
and actually elevate some of those ideas
into a position of political power
and fighting against critical race
theory uh in in
every institution in the united states
and not giving an inch
because if we allow this to essentially
take over our public institutions in my
view
it's the beginning of the end of our
constitutional order and a system of
government that has
shown a steady capacity to adapt and
progress
for nearly uh a quarter millennia man
it's like everything you're talking
about it sounds alarmist
and yet it it's the stuff that we all
now know to be true i mean i i've been
screaming about this without having the
words exactly for
it we there was a bunch of us you just
named a couple of the people
that were screaming about it and
everybody kept saying no no no it's just
a bunch of college kids that was
that was the criticism i was getting
often from you know from mainstream
media people no no it's a bunch of
college kids
you guys are making it up i wonder have
you have you thought about this a little
bit
um that it seems to me that the liberals
the good remaining liberals who whoever
they are
there's not that many left because i
think so many have been sort of either
silenced or um coerced into this crazy
lefty thing
um do you sense that the liberals have
any defense against this
i think this is where i have a bit of a
difference with
some of my friends in this where i think
some of them still think the liberals
have some defense mechanism against this
i simply don't believe that anymore i
think i it's either
the conservatives and in a weird way
it's trump or or bust
what do you think about that yeah i i
100 side with you and i think that um
what we've seen
in seattle and san francisco and los
angeles that the kind of
old-line liberals or the kind of
moderate liberals
really have no ability to push back or
even restrain
the most extreme progressive ideologues
and that
kind of experience in the last 10 years
in these
very liberal cities on the west coast is
now being nationalized in our discourse
and frankly
joe biden is not going to offer any kind
of restraint against this
it's it's completely naive and absurd to
think so i think it's also kind of naive
and absurd to think that there's some
great
third party unity ticket that could
fight against it
the kind of brass tacks of it is that
kind of dissident liberals mainstream
liberals
they have to to create an alliance with
conservatives in order to stop this and
i'm encouraging all of my friends
on the center left to move over and
forge an alliance at least on these
critical issues with us
within the conservative movement because
the bottom line is really this uh kind
of writing an
op-ed no matter how good it is kind of
appealing to civil discourse appealing
to restraint appealing to the center
is not going to change the minds of the
fundamentalists who are running
uh the kind of intellectual architecture
of the left
and they have to basically make the
decision we are going to tactically
align with conservatives to stop this
and i think there's precedent if you
look at the 1970s who became the kind of
neoconservatives
these were a lot of new york
intellectuals that were
liberals that were in some cases even on
the very far left
and they were mugged by reality yeah and
then they moved
over to the right and became kind of
prominent members of this kind of
uh big tent uh kind of conservative
infrastructure
the same thing has to happen today and
i'm
you know really pleading to all of those
folks on the center left
look at the actual political landscape
as it exists
not as you imagine it in your hopes and
dreams let's get together let's push
back
and let's exert some actual political
muscle chris honestly i don't know that
i've ever been more relieved
by an answer that i've ever gotten from
from a guest on the show because i you
know as you know that that
is what i believe and it's it's causing
a certain pain point for me with a lot
of what i would say is my old crew it's
the liberals that can't accept that but
do you think some of
of that the the inability to understand
the landscape as it is not as you want
it to be do you think
the some of the aversion to that is
simply because of trump
that if it was somebody else fighting
this stuff they could get on board
but because it's trump they can't get on
board
yeah i think that's a big part of it and
you know i'll be very honest i've been
very honest with my own views you know i
i didn't vote for the president in 2016.
i shared a lot of the reservations that
a lot of the people on the center left
shared
but i've realized that the world as it
is is a binary system that's been our
political system for almost 250 years
that's how it's going to be for the next
at least 100 years
so we have to operate in a or b and for
me it's a very simple choice
you have joe biden who essentially at
this point is a kind of
armored carapace where he's going to
bust through to the oval office and then
the people
who are driving the movement of
progressivism
are going to man the agencies are going
to man the the kind of facilities and
push this ideology even faster
or trump you know if you have
reservations about his character i get
it if you have reservations about some
of those policies i get it
but he's come out very strongly in the
last 30 days
he's denounced critical race theory by
name and he is the only politician in
in in the united states frankly that
would have done it jeb bush
would be hiding under a desk he wouldn't
want to touch this issue
and uh and i think that the president
for all of his flaws
is someone who's willing to stand
against this and you don't have to like
your allies
you just have to recognize from a
pragmatic point of view that you are
fighting the same battle and when then
that battle's won you can go back to
your separate sides uh but i think that
you know i've come to to realize i'm
gonna be he's the president has earned
my vote
uh specifically because of his action on
these issues and i would encourage folks
if they have to hold your nose uh and uh
and uh and pull down the old lever
yeah i i'm i'm so with you on that and
i'm glad that you explained it as
cleanly as you did
because i think the problem with the
with the last remaining liberals
is they want to write the harpers letter
they want to say all the things address
all the problems
as long as they can say oh but we don't
support that guy who's actually doing
the work
to fix the thing so can we talk about
that a little bit that
trump is actually doing things to get
critical race theory out of our system
and of course he's being called a racist
for it um but can you talk you talked to
tucker about this a little bit can you
talk about what trump has actually been
doing
and not just talking about the libs are
all good at talking about the things
he seems to be actually doing things
yeah that you know the president uh
after uh following some of my reporting
on critical race theory and federal
agencies
uh he immediately uh tasked his omb
director russ vaught
to issue an executive action at his
request to
abolish all critical race theory
trainings throughout the federal
government
this is a pretty bold move and then he
followed it with a speech at the
national archives
where he dismembered the ideology of
critical race theory
uh in actually kind of a surprisingly
intellectual dialogue
uh where he called it out by name uh he
linked it to the 1619 project he linked
it to the riots and the streets that
have been going on uh since
the death of george floyd and he says
these are all
kind of birds of a same feather these
are all uh interlinked phenomenon
and i'm gonna stand against it i'm gonna
essentially put myself in the breach
and fight against it on principle and in
practice and i think
a lot of our friends on the center left
are willing to fight in principle
but they're not willing to fight in
practice and this is a kind of huge
error and i i look at it like this they
were saying we don't want trump to fight
this we don't want him to create this
executive order banning critical race
theory and i'm saying well okay
that's essentially saying we don't we
want to keep losing
because if we win a little bit now there
might be a backlash
that frankly is a defeatist attitude i i
find it
uh totally untenable on the level of
kind of prudential politics
and i would again encourage everyone to
abandon that way of thinking and
and and have some courage and step up
yeah it's one of those things i i liken
it to like you know the barbarians are
at the gate and the one guy who's
guarding the gate still
you got all the intellectuals going ah
he talks funny and his hair is crazy
and it's like guys we got a bigger
problem
on the other side of that gate so then
after after trump issued
this uh this speech and everything else
then he
the cdc they said they were still going
to continue right
but then he put an end to that as well
yeah it's actually multiple federal
agencies i i've reported new
whistleblower documents
from the cdac the epa the veterans
administration and the state department
all of which are moving forward with
critical race theory trainings
in direct violation of a presidential
order and i think this is both a problem
substantively right
uh the kind of principles that are in
these documents are divisive
pseudoscientific racist and and really
destructive for the workplace
but it's also a problem at the level of
our constitutional system
the president is the president he
controls the agencies
and my friends and colleagues at the
claremont institute and elsewhere have
long warned about the administrative
state becoming the
unconstitutional fourth branch of
government and i think this is another
illustration of that pattern where you
have mid-level and even senior
bureaucrats
basically saying we can openly defy the
president
we're going to do what we want even
though nobody elected us and we have
don't have this power in the
constitution
we're going to keep doing it so i think
you know in the
short term this is not a big deal the
omb director will shut these down
but in the long term on on the kind of
theoretical basis
this is a major problem you have an
administrative state uh
that is essentially uh doesn't think of
itself as beholden to the political
order
uh and i think that is a huge problem
and we've got to tackle that uh when the
time comes
in effect i mean you're talking about
the deep state there when you say the
administrators say do you make
a distinction or you just don't like
that phrase or
yeah i i think you know i don't like the
phrase i i think there's a really
kind of strong body of scholarship on
the phrase the administrative state
i think the deep state uh can kind of
converge into kind of conspiratorial
territory
so it's a personal choice but i think
administrative state
is on much more solid intellectual
footing
and and we have a long list of folks
who have done the background done the
homework
done the reading that i would encourage
everyone uh to look up
so let's say through this executive
action trump is
able to get this stuff out of the
federal agencies
it sounds like it's still going to be a
fight to do so and who knows if that's
even really possible but
let's just say that that kind of works
are you worried then that what will
happen is we'll have federal agencies
that will have
removed this stuff but in effect we'll
just have all the private institutions
the private schools all of our all of
our businesses our television networks
all of these things
they will still be infected and that
infection will almost
create a situation where the federal
government will be unable to operate
because the the outside forces
uh won't let the federal government do
what it's supposed to do
something to that effect yeah i mean i i
would kind of
contextualize it in this way i think
we've long been concerned about this for
the last few years uh but this is the
first time that we've actually got
anything done about it
i think it's really substantively the
first successful pushback against
critical race there are institutions
but it's not the first this is really
the opening shot in a long war
and i think that we can start with
federal agencies we can start with other
public institutions
we can kind of shut off the spigot of
funding
that goes towards the university
programs that are creating this
intellectual framework
we can go after local school districts
and local institutions that are that are
funding this
and then what we do is we change the
calculation for corporations that i
think will adapt very quickly
what we need to do is we need to raise
the cost of doing these programs because
right now the
the kind of risk management protocol for
corporations is
well we really don't lose anything by
doing this but we insulate ourselves
against the attack of being a big bad
corporation
and so what they're doing is they're
protecting their economic
kind of their economic prospects with
our existing policies
and their this is a way of risk
management uh for their kind of
social policies and social uh status in
the world
what we have to do is we have to change
that change that formula
where we we significantly escalate the
cost of doing these programs
and i think the next step is clearly uh
a
kind of campaign of legal warfare
against these programs
uh peter kirsten and others have have
argued persuasively that these are
constitute
a workplace harassment that these
violate the equal protection clause
and the civil rights act and i think
that's the next step
and i really think that i'm excited i'm
energized
by this initial victory we have a long
way to go but i think that if we work
together
we get our heads out of the clouds and
we actually
fight kind of swords out on the ground
i think we can win this because i think
the vast majority of americans if they
actually find out what this theory is
is advocating for i would wholeheartedly
reject it
yeah i'm with you man do you think that
there's sort of
a microwave fighting and a macro way of
fighting so it sounds like
like trump and what you just described
there that's sort of the macro level of
we have to fight at the governmental
level but one of the questions i get
all the time especially from college
people is
well how do i fight it just personally
if one of my friends has been
you know just wholly brainwashed by this
set of ideas
and i don't know that there's a great
answer you know i'll tell them well you
know you can share some prageru videos
or some of the you know
listen to larry elder or read a book by
thomas soule but that's sort of all
intellectual stuff in a certain way that
you know often you're not going to get
younger people to take the time to do
have you
do you have any tricks on the micro
level on how to wake people up about
this
i know i don't i actually i've kind of
come to the personal conclusion that
the kind of micro level one-on-one is
probably a waste of time you find
yourself
like debating some dude you went to high
school with on a long facebook thread it
never goes anywhere
i think that this is really at heart an
institutional battle you have to win it
institutionally so rather than arguing
with your roommate
you should be kind of uh waging a kind
of sophisticated campaign against the
dean of your school
and i think that's the way to do it i i
think that unfortunately we're in this
kind of
really awful political environment where
in order to maintain kind of one-on-one
friendships sometimes you just have to
put politics off the table
so i i think again it's an institutional
fight
and that's really where the most
progress can be made yeah
so i said to you right before we started
that i wanted to keep this exactly to a
half hour because this is
the type of video that i want people to
be able to say to their friends even if
what you're saying is right that you
don't want to be debating the facebook
friend
here's a half hour video hopefully you
got some of it
so for people that do want to explore
this more and your work more where can
we send them
yeah come to my website it's christopher
ruffo rufo.com
i'm on twitter at reel chris ruffo again
that's our ufo
uh and you know join the fight join the
fun i mean we are really
waging a very active campaign we're
trying to get things done
uh and my motto is swords out swords up
uh because that's what it's gonna take
chris for real you are fighting the good
fight and i like the fact that you're
enthused about it you know i know
even for me like we get beaten down by
this stuff you wake up every morning
and there's another thing on twitter
about another institution that failed or
just like some other horrible story
and it can get you down but you got a
smile on your face in the midst of this
which is actually got to be a happy
warrior and
i know without a shred of doubt that
we're going to win it might take time
there will be losses uh but we're going
to win this fight
christopher ruffo thanks for joining us
thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell